chris bubich makes start number one of
2021. oh look at those numbers nice and
low right where he wants to keep him if
at all possible how about that it's kept
the ball in the ballpark
look at that that is some paint on the
outside part of the plate perfectly
located now up comes lorenzo kane long
time royal and lorenzo's going to get a
nice hand from the royals fans
for seasons and games well played with
the kansas city royals oh there's his
buddy
zombie looking okay the the banter they
had was priceless it was so fun to watch
these guys engage
that last time he made an appearance
here all right we got it out
last time he came here rhino i think he
wore us out i'm not mistaken and the
fans were cheering him remember that it
was pretty special and here's christian
yelich game number 11
this season for yelich a couple of trips
to the injured list
out to gutierrez
and that is that chris bubich hits the
brewers one two three no score brandon
woodruff yeah he's been outstanding he's
given apollo six runs in his last seven
stars got off to a rough start his first
start of the year three runs in four
innings but lights out since
then he chops one to luis
that's how the night starts for brandon
woodruff
this is carlos santana goes after the
first pitch and lines it to colton wong
and quickly there are two men out here
in the first a lot else has gone right
for kansas city a chopper over to urias
a couple of chances and louise good with
both and brandon woodruff puts him down
one two three
another win picking up in a fly ball out
into
right center field overcomes solaire and
makes the catch and they see garcia is
out number one in the second inning
right into the shift with wit over on
the left side
two down and bubba just set down the
first five
on the ground to whit another jam shot
and forbitch that is six up and six down
and 12 and two thirds consecutive
scoreless innings
with the breaking stuff one-two pitch to
perez and a wave and a miss first strike
out of the night for brandon woodruff
that looked like slider 87 miles an hour
off the outside corner
there it is you see the dot this
rotation on that pitch off the corner
and salvador perez who
is one of those guys he doesn't like to
walk too much
and there's a base hit into center field
for gutierrez with two down here comes
the grounds crew and
so they have made the determination that
it's best to get the tarp on the field
right now before the the rain gets too
heavy the wind is really picked up and
you can tell they're having a little
trouble fighting the wind
back to the middle wit backhands gets to
his feet and that is in time and
whitmerfield is putting on a defensive
clinic tonight
go ahead whitley
man was that smooth look at locain
saying okay all right don't hit it to
center i got you hey this is how the
game rolls watch it watch the ball hop
up to to win it came up to the backhand
side and he had a lot on that throw boy
that's that's one of his best plays all
year right there oh man that was tough
that's fun that that competition there
he's talking to witt
rubick strikes him out and bubic has
three two down in the fourth we'll show
you where bubba you got the former mvp
out change up
it doesn't matter if you're a
right-handed batterer left-handed batter
he's going to throw it to you and he's
getting a lot of those same results
a lot of swinging misses
pitch to taylor he'll swing
a little flare into shallow left center
and comes taylor that is michael taylor
to retire tyrone taylor
oh his change-up's been great
four strikeouts
and he's retired 15 of 16.
on the ground to gutierrez out at second
double play
that'll take care of the lead-off walk
just how he wrote it up
and lorenzo hits it to center taylor
comes up he's got it
and chris bubich has 17 and two thirds
scoreless innings two three and four
hitters for the royals in the sixth
inning carlos santana will lead things
off he's lined out and is grounded out
and he goes after the first pitch and a
fly ball into
left center field lorenzo kane is there
one away a 1-1 pitch
and that's it in the air to right
lots of room for avi garcia for out
number two mcgriff has retired the side
in order three times tonight trying to
make it four and he does pulling the
string on salvador perez and down go the
royals as this scoreless tussle
continues here in kansas city brandon
woodruff remains on the mound for the
brewers
there's a shot to third and reyes might
have been
using his glove as a shield and he'll
throw out jorge silveira and yeah he had
to shake that one off
and a ground ball
for one and the turn room service double
play
and brandon woodruff a model of
efficiency here tonight and brandon
woodruff comes out after seven scoreless
innings
that's just the second walk given up by
woodruff
and he gets nailed
so ben and tendy's coming up craig
council is on the steps and as soon as
he gets on the field there's nothing
woodruff can say and it's an automatic
change and ben tendy hits it into right
field here comes with around third
garcia's got a good arm
whit is gonna be safe
but for now the royals lead one nothing
and they have runners at second and
third
and the brewers will challenge
not sure which foot got in there but did
his hand get in there
oh almost similar to the play in chicago
how about that
did he tag him will the royals
get a little revenge play
a revenge call
yes
we got a call
we know how you feel
but they're not done there's two outs to
see if th some more two out hitting
success
and that is grounded out to short
urea throws high
salvia is safe
and it's two nothing and ureases
defensive problems continue that's his
second error tonight
oh man heir number
nine on the year for him oh man
the royals get two in the bottom of the
eighth on a great night for pitching and
stalmont is going for his fourth save
and he's trying to get jake brents his
first big league victory
[Applause]
down goes yelich
so he takes the hat trick in his first
game back from the injured list
and there are two down in the ninth
rareback and letter fire
high fastball does the job
and now abaseo garcia
that is a low strike garcia doesn't like
it
we better watch it he threw his
left hand in the air in protest
that's a swing and now
garcia is mad at the world and he just
got ejected
ejected
in the middle of an at-bat
in the ninth inning
[Applause]
as the cleanup hitter
i'd like to be able to stick up for him
but when you outwardly show up an umpire
like that
once that's a lot but to do it again
twice and to raise your hands that is a
automatic ejection
you raise your hands at an umpire
now craig council just got thrown out
yeah yes you see that right there
where's the respect and you expect to
stay in the game for that yeah
you got to go now daniel vogelback is
going to come off the bench
and he will inherit a two-ball
two-strike count
and there you go
jake brents gets his first big league
victory and he's already being
congratulated by his teammates